thank you alejandro another player that
bounced back after a difficult defeat
against christopher you is brandon
jacobson brandon welcome the show a big
victory for you how does that feel
yeah i mean i'm happy with the result
but certainly not happy with my play in
any of the games i mean
starting with my game against
christopher like
i over thought my instincts like i
played this ridiculous movie takes v6
when of course in a bluetooth game i go
knight takes b6 and knight c4 and
probably hold
um
and even against mystery yesterday like
how did you deal with that loss that
must have been very disappointing for
you to start like that for sure um
i think i just tried to shake it off and
find my form um
i did just come from two tournaments
back to back so maybe i felt like it was
you know first round nerves whatever it
is um
i tried to forget about it and try to
focus on the next game but then
yesterday too i mean i missed the
special takes h6 move and
would have basically been close to
winning again i didn't trust my
instincts and i'm really thinking the
problem is probably just maybe lack of
confidence maybe nerves i don't know
what what it is but um even today's game
like
it worked out and then but there are
definitely moments where i
could have played more precisely
definitely back and forth but it did
seem like it got the best out of her out
of the opening did you expect her to
play this way
uh yeah so before the game i just looked
at some lines um this knight b2 rookie
one is not the most precise movie i
think already black is supposed to be
quite comfortable after knight g4 and
king h8
um
and
yeah i went for this exchange stack but
um
perhaps we can have that on the board
right now
yeah so knight b2 is inaccurate white
should go h3 here um just to avoid all
this knight g4 king h8
um and then
you know the game goes on h6 rookie h
normal italian
um but yeah knight bd2 knight g4
did you feel like uh she missed that
like what was the yeah i mean i think
she played knight b too quickly i i
think she was probably confusing the
lions um
[Music]
but
yeah i assumed she wasn't familiar with
this knight she four khai idea because
she played knight b two maybe like 30
seconds and she was probably confusing
to move orders she forgot about the
three yeah right and then because there
are some lines where you want to avoid
h3 like black house and castle yet then
you want to avoid five by three because
then h6 and g5 is coming
so
yeah and then she thought for a long
time after f5
um
and i have a lot of options after knight
f1 like a lot of things look tempting
like even this knight back to f6 um but
i figured after bishop e3 like probably
black is better i can go bishop takes e3
and f takes c4 and like knight h5 for
example
and this was actually played at the top
level really most of the top level
players played knight f6
but the best way to continue is taking
and taking reality okay that's that's so
you found the best way over the board
yeah and the game wasn't so sure um but
yeah the problem is you're not exactly
getting mated right away but it's just
sort of long term like she takes f3
knight h6
um like h6
oh
okay okay
well if not f6 at that knight g3 and
then my knight can't go to h5 and then i
wasn't really sure how to proceed i mean
that's probably good too
perhaps i'm
h3
yeah maybe this was good too it should
be three or something
um
things get a bit double-edged right but
the point was that afternoon age takes
like
let's say like it should be three i
don't know what the best move is but at
some point i'm just going to go 97 and
knight g6 and bring the knight to f4 and
it's not it's really uncomfortable for
white like you can go like rookie 3
knight g3 bishop f1 try to hold on but
long term like you have no open files
for your rooks like even if you can
consolidate somehow like black hole is
going to have knight f7 hg5 ideas at the
right moment too great control over the
dark squares right so i figured this had
to have to be better for black um
yeah she took in g4
rook f8 yeah i had this interesting idea
of rook f4 also after hthc was probably
unnecessary but um
i thought it was kind of interesting but
i thought like
minimum white can take on f4 and go like
rook d2 do you have e5
um then i can take on g4 i guess take on
g4 yeah if not h2 then maybe 95 and i
don't know
but okay sure that's probably good too
but i thought minimum like work d2 let's
say instead of net h2
knight e5 maybe they should be two and
if queen h4 then something like rook d4
just
bishop at some point um
so like bishop b2 let's say and then
oh sorry you can't go bishop v2 here um
okay i guess getting my lines because
but basically at some point maybe you
should do now right yeah yeah maybe
but you're still losing that g4 oh no
i don't know yeah there was some line
right where that just like d4 and
stacking perhaps that was okay yeah that
was at some point um before but yeah
rocket fails seems simple enough 93
how did you assess the position yeah i
thought black was close to winning here
and then i played this ridiculous move
queen g5 i mean i totally missed rook f2
which was a really nice move like an id5
i mean queen f6 i'm basically like up a
full tempo on the game within bigger
queen f6 immediately
um i don't really see how she's stopping
like c6 and d5 and this looks almost
lost for white and we saw you on camera
at this point and you looked a bit bit
down a bit disappointed when you saw
this move look to f2 was that yeah the
way you felt i mean this was like maybe
the fifth time this tournament my
opponent plays the move i didn't even
consider it was legal
um and it just felt like everything was
going wrong and i like i figured okay
black of course should still be better
but like i gave her this g3 kg2 and all
of a sudden it's kind of a mess
it's a fight you didn't want to see this
yeah i know for sure yeah i'm not even
sure if d5 was best i mean i can also
play slow with just going c6 first
um
i mean i suppose the position i got in
the game objectively was good for me the
whole time but like it definitely got a
bit messy at some point um
yeah c16 g2 d5 maybe just fly like this
a bit slower
right
um
let's say like
i think d5 was the right decision it was
the right stage it was the right
decision and
not the right decision for her was
actually to take on d5 after that it
seems you're close to winning king james
one of those times where like when you
start missing a lot of moves you start
to second guess everything that you're
seeing so i really
like the one good thing i did this game
was i was able to recognize that i
should just close my eyes and trust my
instincts and stop overthinking my moves
and then like starting around after d5
take bishop takes i started to play fast
and just sort of trust myself and i
think from there it went pretty smooth i
didn't really see any chances for her
after that brandon congratulations uh
big victory for you who do you have
tomorrow um david browski with the white
pieces uh double black
double black that's a difficult game
yeah well congratulations and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you well done brandon
indeed i found i think he played very
well especially the movie